foreign
[Music]
we are currently at 298k Subs the goal
is to get to 300K by the end of this
month
which would be a huge
you know milestone for me 300 would
definitely be nice so every sub counts
and let's get the show on the road
black against 1324 very strong opponent
and we're gonna play as is my officially
recommended line The Accelerated Dragon
hopefully we get an open Sicilian
hopefully we get an open Sicilian we're
praying for T4 but if we don't
that's also valuable you have to know
many anti-sicilians of course there's
the rosalimo bishop E5 and this is the
first time we are facing it
so the bishop B5 is called the rosalima
variation
uh you can think of it almost as the
real Lopez against the Sicilian
and it is the favorite Choice uh among
top players now for well over a decade I
mean Fabiano caruana plays the Royal
salima regularly I myself with the white
pieces Play Bishop B5 almost exclusively
almost never go D4
and the benefit of the rosalimo at a
high level is that it offers a more
positional game
uh in contrast to the open Sicilian and
it is a very very serious way to fight
for the advantage at a high level now at
a lower level people often Play Bishop
B5 without really understanding why
they're playing it they just sometimes
think that they're playing with the real
Lopez and they don't fully understand
the difference
now since we are accelerated Dragon
players in the speedrun we are going to
play the move G6 here there are two
principal ways to play the rosalima with
black G6 is one move and as many in the
chat are indicating the other is E6 so
for people who play let's say the
powellson or who played the taimanov
E6 is a more sensible choice but for
Accelerated Dragon players it is more
consistent to fiancado your bishop and
in this position once again there is a
choice between BC and DC
and if if you think back
all the way to our initial speed run you
might remember a couple of games where
we Face the rosalimo
and you might remember that the main
move for black is actually to play D
takes C6 to capture away from the center
and that is what we're going to do right
now to capture away from the center
but looking at DC just visually you
should immediately begin to realize what
the motivation behind taking away from
the center is there's a couple of things
to notice the first of course is that
you're opening up the diagonal for the
bishop the second is that you're opening
up a line of contact between the queen
and important squares on the D file so
you are increasing your control over the
center
uh by by recapturing with the d-pawn
now we complete our King side
development with Bishop G7 fianchettoing
the bishop
and
in these types of positions white often
plays the move H3 like the players who
who are familiar with rosalimo Theory
end up playing H3
in order to prevent the move Bishop G4
uh but we don't have to play Bishop G4
it's not like trading the bishop for the
Knight is really like that good for
black it's just considered good from a
positional standpoint but we're gonna
play it in a much simpler way I'm going
to try to illustrate a sort of main
rosalimo ideas for black
and
essentially what we're trying to do with
black first and foremost is we're trying
to set our pieces up in such a way that
we fully clamped down on the center and
when you hear this word clamp right
clamp down you should think very often
of two pawns that are dominating let's
say a key square or a key set of squares
so the move that you should be kind of
that should be circulating around your
mind
uh is E7 E5 uh upon which the bishop is
kind of considered an extension of the
pawn the bishop and the pawn are one
unit and what is that one unit doing
they are controlling this very important
D4 Square they're also controlling the
F4 Square they're just basically
controlling key squares in the center
um
but
before we push E5
it's a good idea to carry out the
following maneuver
first we're going to start by playing
Knight F6 and we're going to develop our
Knight to F6
so this is a very flexible move that
doesn't mean that we're not going to
play E5 but what you're going to see is
that if White's Bishop comes out to E3
our Knight's gonna drop back to D7
where it's going to be controlling the
C5 Pawn defending the C5 pawn and
reinforcing the idea of E5
and that is why you often see players in
the rosalimo actually playing Bishop G4
with black
that's why you see players be playing
players playing Bishop G4 with black
because
the drawback of dropping the Knight back
to D7 is of course that it locks in the
bishop on C8 and you might say well
what's the problem with then fee and
ketoing the bishop to B7 well there
aren't that many prospects on this other
diagonal because then it'll be hemmed in
by the C6 spawn
so if you want to play this like a
positional Pro
we first play Bishop G4 we trade the
bishop for the Knight then we drop the
Knight back to D7 we push E5 and our
remaining two minor pieces are both
uh very much involved in the process of
controlling the center Bishop takes F3
there we go
now we drop our Knight back to D7
and the reason we play Knight D7 first
is that E5 immediately allows white the
additional option of developing his
Bishop to G5 and trading the bishop off
for the Knight this Knight is an
integral player in our control over the
center and now finally we sort of
complete our initial Central plan with
the movie five
um hopefully that has made sense now our
opponent is demonstrating complete
knowledge of all the key ideas which is
pretty impressive A4
white is grabbing some space on the
queen side
white is grabbing some space on the
queen side
now we want to join the party we don't
want to let white just Advance this Pawn
to A5 and clamp down our Queen side so
what should we do
how should we well we should meet white
at the top
what move does that entail
so B6 doesn't actually prevent white
from playing A5 in fact I would argue
that B6 makes A5 even more annoying it
kind of gives some fuel to the fire I
would just play A5 yeah just clamp down
and prevent white from making further
progress on the queen side
yeah so as buddy indicates in the chat
our subsequent plan in this position is
to Castle kingside and then push F5 and
start a king Side Pawn attack much like
in a lot of openings like the king's
Indian uh there are a lot of openings
where you have this plan of pushing the
F Pawn on the king side
and that's another reason that we fee
and ketoed our dark squid Bishops so
that when we push F5
uh we don't have to worry too much about
weakening our King side 92 I mean our
opponent is playing uh fantastic
positional game so far we castle
kingside of course
and I assume our opponent is guiding his
Knight toward G3 in order to prevent F5
wow okay
well we don't give up on our plans that
easily
we don't give up on our plans that
easily
how can we reinforce the idea of F5 well
ideally you would have like a bishop
that would be on E6 here but in this
case
you have to make do with what you have
so who can tell me like what piece
uh can we bring to what square and if
you're watching on YouTube try to pause
and figure this out in order to
reinforce the threat of F5 we have to
use the Queen We simply have to use the
queen now from what Square could the
queen prepare a five
no I'll can prepare a five from the E6
Square
so let's start with the move Queen E7
not Queen C8 the problem with Queen C8
is that the Knight is blocking the
Queen's access to F5 and then moving the
Knight involves giving up the C5 Pawn so
you would have to additionally play B6
and then you have to move the Knight
away to B8 that seems to be
uh rather cumbersome here we've already
put our Queen on E6 and we are already
prepared to play F5
could you explain Queen E7 over Queen E8
well the only reason I chose Queen E7
over Queen E8
uh is that uh it kept the Rooks
connected that's really all there was to
it
her opponent is
preparing before okay let's think about
this for a second
yeah this is far from Easy of course
so of course
candidate move number one is the move F5
and F5 looks very appealing indeed It
prepares a fork with F4
but the the genius of our opponent's
play
uh positioning the Knight on G3 was
actually very smart from our opponent's
perspective because the move F5 can
actually be met with e takes F5 G takes
F5 and the Knight can jump out to this
H5 square and everybody should kind of
understand that that H5 square is is
rather annoying because it pressures the
bishop on G7
and if the bishop in that position drops
back to h8 then there's another check on
G3 so things kind of get a little bit
dicey on the king side but dicey doesn't
mean insurmountable or unmanageable
and I don't think that Knight H5 is a
deal breaker we've done all of this in
order to play F5 I think we should
follow through we don't have much else
that we can do here
perhaps some of you noticed the move
Queen to B3 but then White's Queen can
drop back to D1 and an end game is
definitely not in Black's favor here
given that we are the one with a damaged
Pawn structure on the king side on the
queen side
okay so far our opponent is playing very
very well Knight H5 here is what I would
play with white
not an easy move at this level but I
think he's gonna find it
this doesn't feel positional as black
says Eric the Red well I think saying
something
does or does not feel positional is is
kind of relative we're kind of following
the prescribed method in this position
and I'm cutting some Corners with black
I will fully admit that the way that I'm
playing this position with black is not
how we're going to play it when we're
like 2 000 right I'm just trying to kind
of illustrate the skeletal basic plans
in the position to give you a sense of
how to play
uh otherwise it's very hard to teach you
know these conceptual openings like the
rosalimo properly if I kind of throw all
the theory at you then you're kind of
going to get lost in the complications
hopefully I've managed to illustrate the
general plans thus far
so what are we threatening well we're
threatening the move F4 that would Fork
the two minor pieces
okay so white can't just blindly follow
through with his plan of B4
white has to move one of the minor
pieces
apart from F4
we also have a rather
a rather uh extensive assortment of
improving moves like for example what
are some moves that we could play to
improve our position well we could bring
the a rook into the game with Rook a to
E8 and I always recommend on your
opponent's turn if the position is not
overly tactical to kind of generate
these lists of General improving moves
that you could play Not only does that
make your play more efficient but
it's kind of the prescribed method at uh
at a high level to think conceptually on
your opponent's turn
and then think more concretely on your
own turn I think that's a pretty good
way to apportion
the thinking time Bishop to D2 so
there's a couple of ways to handle this
position we could play Rook a to E8
but there is a move here that I actually
really like and it's it's a move that I
think not a lot of players would
necessarily look at instinctually it's
it's a move that offers a queen trade
I'll give you a pretty big hint
and the point of this move isn't just to
offer the queen trade it's to fix the
queen Side Pawn structure and to knock
off whites very nastily placed Queen on
F3 this queen on F3 is is really well
placed for white because it it halts the
progress of our King side Pawns
and it and it aims at the queen side so
if white ever plays the move B4 it can
combine with the Rook to exert pressure
on our Queen side
so the move I'm I have my eye on is
actually Queen E6 to D5
so we have a positional threat of taking
White's Queen and ruining White's
kingside Pawn structure not the end of
the world for white but still a pretty
big gain if we're playing Black
if white plays Knight takes F5 that
fails tactically and you should see that
then we take the queen on F3 white has
an intermediate check on E7
but in that position who can tell me
which way we go with our King
so in that position do we go to h8 or do
we have a different Square
simple calculation just testing your
visualization yeah King F7 right that's
a classic method where then white has to
waste the tempo taking back our queen
and the King takes the Knight on E7 we
are up a piece
so Knight takes F5 Queen takes F3 G
takes F3 Rook takes F5 wins the piece
if white accedes to the queen trade then
we get a massive Pawn Center we get four
pawns on the fourth rank
and in that situation we'll be prepared
to continue steamrolling white with E4
so we're posing a rather difficult
decision to White and we're improving
the placement of our own Queen
uh so it's a it's a rather nasty
positional move uh to face I think for
white
hopefully that explanation made sense
Mamba on Discord asks doesn't Queen
takes D5 create a hole on B5 it does I
can't argue with that but what can
possibly occupy that hole can you
envision a future where the White Knight
on G3 gets to B5 perhaps but that's
going to take the knight at least
four or five moves and that's an
eternity in a chess game our gains are a
lot more immediate than the hole on B5
and remember almost everything's going
to have some drawback you're going to be
able to look at almost every move and
say well this creates a hole this
creates a weakness Queen E2 best move by
the way by our opponent that's very very
strong uh keeping the Queens on the
border our opponent understands that
that is the way to keep fighting for the
advantage with white
so now we have to keep finding ways to
improve our position and I have a couple
of ideas
so of course I think the most obvious
move in the position as many of you are
indicating is in fact Rook 8 E8 but
that's not the only way that we could
use our Rooks uh to try to pressure the
king side another interesting idea would
be well if our Rooks were doubled on the
f-file right let's imagine for a second
that we had Rooks on F7 and f8 you might
then notice that you have this idea of
playing F4 now F4 is a positionally
very risky move why is it so
positionally risky because it gives up
this massive Square in the center for
the Knight it gives up the E4 square but
if the Rooks were doubled on the f-file
then you would be able to push the pawn
all the way to F3 and provoke massive
weaknesses on White's King side it would
probably be worth it to do so
so one idea here is actually to play
either Rook F7 or even Rook up to F6
and the reason
uh I like a move like Rook F6 is from F6
The Rook could perhaps double back to G6
and put some pressure on White's G2 Pawn
so that would be an interesting way to
go
but conversely the benefit of playing
Rook F7
is that the Rook nf7 is a nice defensive
piece it's kind of protecting the bishop
it's protecting the king and it's also
protecting the B7 Pawn
so I actually want to go for Rook F7 if
you think about it let's not forget that
white had this old idea of playing B4
white plays C4 okay
that is music to my ears
because it's kind of one move it is
white attacks the queen but white
weakens the D3 Pawn now this is a
serious weakness it's a backward Pawn
and correspondingly there is now a very
juicy Outpost that's been created on D4
and our Knight on D7 is only three moves
away from exploiting that Outpost Knight
f8 96 and Knight D4 is gonna pop
probably come next where should we move
the queen should we move it to E6 should
we move it to D6 or should we move it up
to D4 and occupy the Outpost
well you should rule out Queen D4 you
shouldn't occupy outposts with a queen
because it's way too vulnerable you
should drop it back to D6 this is the
nicest Square because they're aiming at
the D3 pawn queen E6 would kind of Step
into the pin and it would allow a nasty
move like F4 which by the way white
could play anyway I would maybe even
play F4 with white but the queen on D6
is clearly the best of the three squares
available to the queen
how do I see these Night Moves well it's
not that hard right it's just all about
charting a course you notice the
destination square and then you just ask
yourself how do I get there in the
fastest possible way
now we have to be careful
because there's this Pawn on A5 which is
going to be hanging if we play rookie 8
too quickly
so we should definitely consider
throwing in the move B6 in order to
reinforce the A5 Pawn so that we don't
have to worry about that headache of
course we could sacrifice the pawn on A5
that is not out of the question if we
can
you know for desperate or if we believe
that the importance of getting the
Knight let's say to D4 supersedes the
importance of corner Pawn then we would
sacrifice A5 but I don't really see the
need for that in this position I think
we have the luxury here of making sure
that everything is protected
um so we have a couple of candidate
moves we can play Knight f8
but the problem with Knight f8 is that
White's gonna go Rook F to E1
and if we then go 96 we actually drop
this very important Pawn on E5
so we can modify our strategy a little
bit we can go Knight f8 rook fe1 and
then we can go Knight to G6 and Knight
to G6 defends the pawn on E5 and also
aims for the F4 Square it's not as good
as the E6 square but it's still a pretty
solid defensive score for the Knight
we could also take a slower approach we
could say let's not move the knight at
all yet let's start with the move B6
then let's bring the Rook to E8 let's
try to shore up all of our weaknesses
first and then maybe later we'll have an
opportunity to get the Knight around to
D4
so I think all of these options make a
lot of sense
I think that we should probably try to
play as solidly as possible given that
our opponent is playing Super well so
let's play B6 and let's play rookie 8
and let's keep as many of our options
open for the night as possible
well doubling Rooks and going F4 is no
longer the appropriate idea because if
you play F4 Knight E4 now comes with
tempo
right so we won't really be able to
shove this Pawn all the way down to F3
and if you think about it after f494 if
you have to spend a Tempo moving your
queen you give white then the
opportunity to play the move F3 himself
and close down the possibility of us
going F3 and we certainly don't want to
give away the C4 Square for free
okay
so we're just making General improving
moves right now this is a stage of the
game in which you shouldn't like
overthink it we're just bringing pieces
into the game we're protecting our weak
pawns and we're awaiting an opportunity
to make further improvements with our
minor pieces
so our next move most likely is going to
be Rook A8 to E8 in order to reinforce
the pawn on E5
and you might say well shouldn't we
reinforce the pawn on F5 and we can but
I have a feeling that at some point
white might be it white might be likely
to play a move like F4
and if he does do that wouldn't we want
to have a rook on this file if the
e-file ever opens up it's a good idea to
already have a rook there so that we can
fight for it in addition the actual
reason that I play rookie 8 is so that
the Knight is free to roam about the
cabin we could not go Knight f8 here
because that would blunder the pawn on
E5 whoop that is none of those eras were
accurate white has one two three
attackers and we would have only had two
Defenders on E5 so we're adding a
defender in order to be able to maneuver
the Knight over to G6
and the reason we'd maneuver the Knight
to G6 is not just so that the Knight
again defends E5 but rather as a
destination Point as a Transit point to
F4 Frankfurt Airport
yeah one could say that we are over
protecting the E5 Pawn to use nimsavichi
in terms and overprotection is just
protecting something more times than is
strictly necessary in order to free up
pieces that are currently defending the
pawn if you're over protecting a pawn
that means you don't need to be
protecting it as many times that means
some of the pieces can go do other
things F4 played by our opponent okay
what we're gonna do now
is try to exploit a drawback of the move
F4
now it would be very nice wouldn't you
agree
if we could reposition our F Rook to E7
if we could double Rooks on the e-file
well that would be pretty nice because
the e-file is very likely to open but we
can't do that because the pawn on F5 is
going to be hanging so which piece could
we shift to what Square yeah and a lot
of you guys are already pointing this
out Queen D6 to G6 is a nice way of
simultaneously attacking the Knight
which has been loosened by White's last
move and
protecting the F5 Pawn making it
possible for us to shift our Rook to E7
which to remind you once again we are
doing because the e-file is very likely
to open up once white plays F takes E5
now unfortunately there's the very
annoying move Knight H5 which
consistently with our opponent's level
thus far he should be should be well
within his level
and after Knight H5
I most certainly no he plays Queen F3
okay
so Queen F3 I think allows us
to continue with our plan and play Rook
F to E7 doubling our Rooks on the e-file
now as a consequence of that we are now
able to move the ephon previously we
couldn't play e takes F4 because the
Rook on E8 would be hanging
now we have at our disposal two
possibilities we can play e takes F4 or
in some cases we can push the pawn to E4
F take C5 our opponent strikes first
what should we recapture with well we
can reach that calculationally because
if we take with the bishop we walk into
Knight takes F5
and then if we take the knight in that
position white plays Knight takes E7
check winning both of our Rooks so we
have to take with a knight
and the point is that if Queen takes F5
the Knight on G3 is dropped
and if white plays Bishop takes E5 we
can take back with a rook
and if white takes with the Rook we
again take with our rook and the F5 Pawn
is protected
now I realize that I've miscalculated I
think our opponent has
wait no oh there's a beautiful detail at
the end oh my gosh I really hope this
happens
so what I missed after Rook takes C5 is
that white can play Rook take C5
Rook takes C5 and now Rook to F1 when
there is no way for us to defend the F5
Pawn
but we have a beautiful tactical
solution in that position
let's see if our opponent Falls for it I
mean our opponent has not fallen for
much of anything thus far
and I will admit I have gotten outplayed
more or less I I don't think we're worse
if this tactical idea I have generated
actually works out for us 92.
no our opponent does not fall for it
okay
so what do we do now yeah rookie three
very nice
so now I think it's a good idea for us
to try to immediately claim
dominance over the e-file right the
e-file is the only open file on the
board and as I've shared many many times
before when there is only one open file
generally speaking you want to be the
one to control that file first
so how do we do that well the move Queen
E6 comes to mind but if you think about
it carefully Queen E6 allows white to
step into F4 with Tempo and you don't
want to allow Tempo moves in an open
position so can we do the same thing but
without allowing a Tempo move
yeah Queen E8 is what we're gonna play
now Bishop H6 is a very sensible move
that some of you are suggesting as a way
to safeguard and secure the E3 Square
maybe go Rook E3 next I like Bishop H6
but I think for the time being keeping
the bishop fiancherod is a more flexible
approach I think Queen E8 is a little
bit more to the point
so let's see it also poses white with a
decision and decisions are never fun
especially when one side is getting low
on time
so let's see where white goes and
normally for you know
players in the 1300 range you know these
types of decisions are very difficult
where to put the Knight and notice that
if the Knight moves if the Knight moves
away from E2 we have the possibility of
trading off the Rooks with rookie one
check and that could be beneficial to us
if we determine that the bishop is
stronger than the knight in the
resulting position which we're going to
have to calculate based on where white
puts their Knight
metaphor
so I see immediately two candidate moves
the first is the move Rook to E3 which
everybody should see that drives the
queen out of F3 and it paves the way for
the bishop to drop into this very nice
D4 Square we're starting to make
progress the second move and the more
concrete approach to the position is of
course to play rookie one check so let's
calculate rookie one check rookie one
check
Rook takes C1
Queen takes E1 check
King H2
and then in that position we can step
into E5 with the bishop pinning the
Knight
but in that position white can unpin the
Knight by playing Pawn to G3
and
I'm just not totally convinced that
black has enough to win the game in that
position so from the perspective of
playing for a win
I think the way to do it is in fact to
play rookie 3 keeping the tension
moreover we have a really pretty tactic
after Queen F2 I think we can win a pawn
I'm actually not totally convinced that
winning the pawn is the best that we can
do there
no Queen F2 loses
Queen F2 loses white has to find Queen
F1 not Elementary and our opponent
borders the queen in one move
and again it's consistent with the
pattern that we've kind of observed
which is that players can play really
really well at this level like really
really well at this level but the moment
you start putting serious pressure and
creating a lot of threats in a row
blunders are incredibly common
and I I think we've seen that over and
over and over again Knight D5 let's
finish the game off in style
obviously do not play Rook takes D3 it's
never too late to blunder I think a lot
of you would play Rook takes D3 missing
the fork on E7
so anytime the Knight is in close
proximity to the king and the queen you
look very very carefully at potential
forks and you keep the Rook on the
e-file rookie two is a move that both is
active and protects the E7 Square
yeah I mean excellent game by our
opponent I I honestly have to say I was
pretty close to getting outplayed there
and I think he's totally legit I mean as
was evidenced by Queen takes C6
so Rook F1
now
again we should be careful not to play
Queen G6
walking into Knight F4 with a fork
so we just have to sort of sidestep
these potential Forks
and I think the best way to do it
is probably let me think for a second
to play Queen to D6 actually Queen to D6
and the point is just to drive the queen
into G3
if and that is anti-climactic but that's
the speedrun for you it's a mixed bag
I'm sure we'll get our share of
thrilling finishes this just didn't
happen to be one of them but that
doesn't mean there isn't plenty to talk
about in this game there is
Queen G3 is game over notice that 97
check the Rook is still protecting that
square Knight F6 check we play Bishop
takes F6
and we basically have two sources of
threats here there is the Checkmate in
one threat Queen takes G2
and if it's defended with Knight F4 then
there's the second category of made
threats on the back rank with rookie one
so there's no way to defend against both
threats at the same time
and he doesn't and we win and we cross
1200.
all right tough game 33 moves
let's analyze
so once again
this is the Russell limo and it is
considered
not even a second it's not a sideline it
is a main line
alongside the move d4 Bishop B5 is sort
of the second Main Line against Knight
C6
and that is why some players who play
The Accelerated Dragon they like to
start with the move G6 this is actually
called the hyper accelerated Dragon but
there is no free lunch and the drawbacks
of G6 greatly outweigh the benefits so
the drawback of the immediate G6 is that
C3 the allopin is actually very very
annoying against the early G6 in
addition white has D4 C takes D4 and
queen takes D4 which is a whole this is
not better for white but it's a whole
other opening that you have to know
so that's why I don't recommend G6 in
the speed run we allow the rosalimo and
we just learn how to play against it
so as I mentioned the two main moves
here are E6
and G6 and the way you choose a move is
based on what you play uh traditionally
what you play against D4
if you play E6 or E5 or you're a
saveshnikov player then most of the time
you play E6 and vice versa which is not
to say that accelerated Dragon players
are not allowed to play E6 or that you
can't learn this but I just think this
is more consistent with with what we
normally play if that makes sense so G6
Bishop takes C6
now recently uh players including Wesley
so who recommends this in his chessable
E4 course I myself with white I play a
cross between the rosalimo and the
alapan Sicilian that is recommended by
Wesley which is to Castle
Bishop G7 and now to play the move C3
and this has gained a lot of steam in
recent years
uh in fact I would say it's overtaken
Bishop takes C6 in popularity this this
C3 line
and after Knight F6 white actually
usually defends the e-pawn with rookie
one you've probably seen me play E5 and
Blitz which is the sideline and it's
really interesting but it's equal
rookie one is a very serious attempt at
an advantage and here the main line goes
castles
white occupies the center with D4
and as is so often the case how does
black usually deal with uh this imposing
Center how does black counter strike in
the center
yeah this is not the elephant this is a
completely different opening this is the
Russell demo
so as a sicilian player you should
remember
that the move here is D5 yeah D5
so e some of you are suggesting E5 is
very awkward E5 is very awkward it
closes down the bishop and after a D5 I
think you're also likely to just lose
the pawn on E5 now this is this just
looks
um yeah this looks awkward
of course if you're not comfortable
playing D5 then you should play the move
D6 but clearly after D6 white normally
plays H3 to stop Bishop G4
uh here black is slightly worse Black is
cramped so the theoretical move is
actually D5 and the idea is to carve out
this very powerful Square for the Knight
and you might say well but what about
the bishop isn't the bishop now biting
on granite and it is and that's called a
complicated position right not
everything is perfect but later on in
the game another idea that you should be
very familiar with when there is a pawn
chain
ideally you want to attack the tip the
sorry the base of the pawn chain but
here you can't do it right if you
compare this kind of structure let's say
to the advanced French in the advanced
French you get the same structure but
you have the capacity of attacking D4
you do so by piling up with your pawns
and your pieces now fast forwarding to
this position you can't really
orchestrate an effective attack on D4
so the next best thing often is to uh
break up the tip of the pawn chain which
is not ideal but often opens up the
piece and that's why as many of you are
pointing out one of Black's main ideas
in this position is indeed to push the F
Pawn to F6
okay
which is not to say that Queen B6 is not
a common move in this position
uh as well it most certainly is but F6
happens frequently as well
anyways you can analyze this on your own
I'm sure we'll probably get this again
uh later on in the speed run in this
game white plays the traditional line
which is to trade on C6 and to push the
pawn to D3
okay so D3 is played we played Bishop G7
Knight C3
and Knight to F6 now checking reference
I can see that E5 immediately is also
considered a viable continuation and
then developing the Knight to E7
but the problem is that Knight on E7 is
heavily restricted by The Pawn on e4
Robert Hess likes to point this out in
his commentaries for example let's say
White Castles and black plays 97 what I
don't like about this position is that
the Knight just has no prospects it's
dominated by The Pawn on e4
so that's why I wanted to reposition the
Knight on a slightly better Square the
D7 Square
um but the main reason you play DC
rather than BC as I explained after the
game BC is a totally viable alternative
there is a ton of theory in BC as well
so again you should always take my
opening recommendations with a grain of
salt and you should not assume that the
alternative move is somehow a mistake in
most cases in the first 10 12 moves it's
just an alternative
but DC opens up the light squared bishop
and increases our control over key
Central squares by opening up the D file
for our Queen
so D3 Bishop G7 Knight C3 we decided on
Knight F6 which is also a very popular
move castles and we take the opportunity
to bring the bishop out to G4
that is why uh most grand Masters in
this position play the move H3 to keep
this bishop relatively uh confined and
black still goes Knight D7 that is still
the main line
white normally develops the bishop black
plays E5 in this position has occurred
thousands of times white is considered
to be a smidge better here but it's just
a very strategically complex game just a
very strategically complex game
um white plays Queen D2 a lot of the
time to prepare Bishop H6 now black
prevents Bishop H6 by pushing the pawn
up to H6 uh castles King side
uh white black often plays B6 here and
yeah there are hundreds of games uh all
all throughout these lines and one of
White's main ideas in this position
is actually to prepare the f-pawn uh the
F4 Pawn break you often see white uh
driving the night back let's say Knight
H2 and then quickly trying to push F4 to
open up the king side and then attack on
the king side exploiting the fact that
black cannot easily Castle kingside or
risk dropping the pawn on H6
and what you will often see is that the
knight from D7 who can remind me what is
the night sort of Ideal maneuver from
this position
and I mentioned this during our game
this is also very pertinent in this
position
the knight from D7
travels to Frankfurt airport Knight f8
and then from f8 Maneuvers to E6
with the dual purpose of controlling the
F4 square and discouraging white from
playing F4 that is why most people play
F4 here while it's not too late but
after EF Bishop f496 the secondary idea
is to control this all-important D4
Square which can be used as an outpost
for the Knight you can play Knight C4 on
the very next move and there are still
dozens of games in this position
so something like this constitutes uh
the sort of traditional main line of the
rosalimo but here our opponent castles
allowing us to uh to get rid of this
bishop so that it doesn't constitute a
headache a little bit later in the
middle game hopefully that makes sense
so we play Knight D7
Bishop E3 we push E5 reaching kind of
our Target setup with these two pawns
clamping down on the D4 Square
and if I were playing white here I would
probably choose to carry out the F4 Pawn
break anyway
who can tell me a nice way that white
can prepare F4 like what is necessary in
order for white to play F4
where should the queen go is really what
I'm asking no folks come on bringing
over the Knight is that necessary the F4
square is already protected by the
bishop by The Rook by potentially by the
queen so the best move is Queen G3 you
want to kind of Step the queen over to
the side onto a relatively invulnerable
Square you see a lot of players they
play for example Queen D1 but that move
ruins the coordination between the Rooks
and you want to keep the queen around
right just want to keep it on a square
where it doesn't interfere Queen G3 is
the best move castles and white can
safely push F4
now now here what would black do well
for black we already know some of the
ideas you guys can already generate a
move based on what you know well what do
you know well one thing that we already
know is that the knight's ideal square
is E6 so what move prepares the long
night maneuver
the Fool's ghost got it you deserve a
sub the best move according to the
engine as I see here is in fact Rook E8
and this move should already make
perfect sense to you first of all you're
bringing the Rook onto a better Square
obviously and you're controlling the E5
Square so you might play Knight E5 but
more likely you'll play Knight f8 96 and
Knight D4 as is typical
another move is Queen B6 here just
trying to harass the pawn on B2 and of
course exploiting the fact the white
can't push B3 uh because he loses the
Knight white has to play this awkward
move and now you can use the X-ray
against White's King to play the move C4
check trying to improve your queen Side
Pawn structure
and if Bishop E3 you can throw in the
move Bishop D4 look how active Black's
pieces suddenly are and here black has
solved all of his problems or her
problems
LAX enhancer asks isn't rookie Aid
giving up some defense of the F4 Pawn
again and again and again when you play
an opening like the Sicilian most moves
in a complicated middle game are going
to have some drawbacks but to that you
should ask yourself are you really
worried about white winning the F7 Pawn
right defending something isn't an
inherent good or an inherent inherently
bad thing it's just a fact of the
position not defending something doesn't
again constitute a bad thing if that
something cannot be effectively attacked
so you could say well okay
can white attack F7 well in order for
white to attack F7 White's gonna have to
move their Bishop out of f4
and after Bishop E3 Knight f8 you just
calculate don't be afraid to calculate
well this drops the C5 Pawn
so that doesn't really work but let's
throw in the move B6
and okay what if white plays Queen F2 is
this dangerous can we not defend these
F7 no we absolutely can how should we
defend the F7 Pawn who can tell me
thank you
no no no no no no don't go F6 come on
guys don't go F6 don't go 95. the Knight
is earmarked for f8 and E6 the best move
is Queen E7
rookie seven is a little bit awkward
it's just yeah it blocks the queen it
sets up a potential pin so now you can't
play Knight f8 because of Bishop G5
so the most harmonious move is Queen E7
notice that the pawn on C6 here
restricts the Knight on C3 preventing
Knight D5 which is actually very
important otherwise Knight T5 would be a
problem so look at how every kind of COG
in the machine is important you have to
appreciate the placement of every piece
and how it's impacting the position what
squares are important to control and
what squares are not important to
control
okay white can play Bishop G5 even here
but you can just like first of all you
can play Queen E6 second of all I think
tactically this move actually works
there there there
and you could play a move like Bishop E5
and prepare Queen G3 and look at how
weak the dark squares are around White's
King I think black has full compensation
here
so anyways we kind of went far there but
that's what I would do with white
our opponent played I wouldn't say
aimlessly I mean our opponent played
quite quite decently
uh A4 we met with A5 and our opponent
decided to maneuver the Knight to G3
which is actually a very impressive idea
for this level to prepare uh to prevent
F5
and our idea stemmed from the fact that
we want to play F5 so we bring our Queen
up to E6
white plays C3 and here we decided to
take the plunge and play F5
now I'd like to point out that there
actually wasn't really any hurry I think
in a classical game I would err on the
side of playing a move like B6 first
because there is no like instant hurry
to play F5
I exaggerated during the game indicating
that B4 is dangerous B4 is actually not
dangerous now that I look at it
carefully because it does a lot more
harm than good and after a takes before
c takes B4 I want to point out an
instructive idea
so here for black the best move is Rook
takes A4
and who can tell me the best move after
B take C5 this is an instructive move
that you should come up with pretty
instinctively
yeah so what you shouldn't do is play BC
because your pawns are terrible this is
like the worst extra Pawn in the world
not to mention you'll probably lose it
back the best move is B5 right classic
move creating a protected passer and
this is the most well protected Pawn on
the whole board
meanwhile white is the one who's got the
weak Pawn on C5 the bishop is tied down
to it and you could later attack it with
Queen E7
so this is like an important way to
uh successfully resolve the tension on
the queen side it's better than playing
C takes before which is also not bad you
could play like this
but if you play like this you give the
Rook a nice Square on C4 and you create
for yourself a a backward Pawn on B6
which could be easily pressured by the
other Rook from B1
so if you just consider the ways to
transform the queen side structure Rook
A4 and B5 is by far the best
so I would have played B6 but we decide
decided in the game to play more
decisively with F5 the engine actually
likes it takes takes and Bishop to D2
dropping the bishop back
here we decided to move the queen in to
D5 which I think is a very reasonable
move
um
flame and Cornbread asks an interesting
question why not B5 to undouble the
punts well the answer is simple White's
not going to take on B5 right
and you might say well then you take on
A4 but again it's the same logic as B
take C5 being bad after B takes A4 yeah
you win a pawn technically but look at
the damage you're doing to your Pawn
structure you're damaging your Pawn
structure permanently so with white I
would play a move like Knight H5 here I
would just ignore the possibility of ba
so don't
assume that your opponent is going to
cooperate in whatever you want to do
um
how do you determine in that position
you should aim for F5 well it's it's a
stock plan it's a typical plan in this
position
and well the reason I'm able to see that
F5 is good is because attacking the king
side with your pawns is just inherently
good as well as the fact that it
threatens F4 so it actually pushes
White's minor pieces off of their
squares
um in the events of the move Knight H5 I
think we would have just driven the pawn
into F4 anyway
and notice that I modify my play based
on my bone opponent's move who can
remind me
why the move F4 is positionally bad in
this situation for example in this and
other similar situations
why is F4 bad
because of 94 yeah and this is a monster
square but it's a monster Square only if
it's occupied by a knight
but if white plays Knight H5 then we can
play F4 and the Knight is excommunicated
it's out of commission it's trapped so
probably white is going to end up
trading it up for the bishop
but now we are more than happy to give
up the E4 Square
because there's nothing good that can
occupy it and furthermore we could even
push C4 on doubling our pawns so B5
actually is the right idea but C4 forces
white to take on C4 or allow C takes D3
and there is nothing good to occupy E4
this is a very important concept and
it's never really too early
to understand it it's the notion that a
weak Square does not exist in a vacuum I
call it the notion of inaccessibility
right it's like if a tree falls in the
forest did anybody hear it if a weak
Square exists and there is no piece to
occupy it with then it's not even really
a weak square and you shouldn't be too
worried about weakening it so
you should always ask yourself like can
my opponent access the weak square and
can they do it in a timely fashion and
if the answer is no very often you can
make a move that would otherwise be
totally unthinkable
and there's always a go-to example that
I indicate in this case and I've I've
shown it during the speed run before
um but it's one of my favorite
illustrations of this concept
um and it's it's not a very well-known
game this is a game between two very
strong GM's as you can see sergation
Armenian GM so muchevsky is a Russian GM
2013 and they reached the position that
you see in front of you
so it's it's white to move
and the goal is to generate the best
move
and the real goal is to well is to gain
a positional Advantage for white so I'll
give you guys a moment to think about
what Black's main idea is
and if you've listened carefully to the
theme then the move should make perfect
sense right at the outset White's a move
and if you're watching on YouTube you
should similarly pause and try to
generate the move even if you're a
beginner
you should still kind of understand this
concept so I would encourage everybody
to try
foreign
and some of you may remember this
position I mean I've shown it before
but it's worth showing again
so
let's take a step back and most of you
are getting the move and figure out the
ideas for both sides which are actually
very simple White's attacking on the
queen side so white is ready to
engineer and carry out the B5 Pawn break
and create major weaknesses for black on
the queen side
um but black of course is threatening to
push E5 and open up the center
exploiting eventually the weakness on E3
so for example if we were to push B5
prematurely black would trade and play
E5
and in the event of the trade the Knight
would then jump to C4
and the attack on the E3 Pawn would
become very unpleasant so sargassian
plays the brilliant move F4
and it's brilliant because it's
seemingly anti-positional he closes down
the bishop but more importantly he
creates this gaping hole on e4 but of
course the key is that black cannot
physically occupy the square with his
Knight in order to do so black needs one
two three four five six seven eight
moves to get there with his Knight
and of course the reason is that G5 is
not accessible and D6 is not accessible
the two airports are closed and in the
time the black spends trying to get his
Knight there white is already going to
break through on the queen side a
million times over which is basically
exactly what happened now I'm not going
to pretend that white is winning after
F4 but it makes Black's life incredibly
difficult
so this concept of something not a weak
Square not being accessible is really
important and often a reason to create
that weakness in the first place yeah
black Canon probably should have played
G5
but after G5 we can ignore and we can
just play B5
right again remember the concept of just
ignoring your opponent's Pawn play you
don't always have to engage them GF you
play EF and who does the opening of the
e-file benefit well it only benefits
white because there's a weak Pawn that's
sitting on E6
this game ended no white one white
actually did win this game
so let's go back to the speedrun
um that was a very long-winded
explanation I admit but I think it's a
very pertinent concept we weaken E4 only
because white no longer has a knight
that can occupy it and in this position
I think black is not worse
after DC we can even consider pushing
the other Pawn with E4 and we've got a
lot of prospects for our pieces
so in any case
Bishop D2 Queen D5 Queen E2
so here we played the generals kind of
solidifying move Rook F7 somewhere
around here I think objectively I got a
worse position I like our opponent's
move C4
at first glance I was very pessimistic
about it I thought it creates a big
weakness on D4 but our opponent's idea
was very concrete and it was to improve
the placement of his bishop and put
pressure on the E5 Pawn
so now we took a Tempo to play B6 I
think this is an important move
protecting the A5 Pawn
rook fe1 and we bring our Rook to E8 so
this part of the game is very logical
and then we get the next stage of the
game after F4
so I don't think F4 is a mistake I think
white is still doing fine here
we played Queen G6 sliding the queen to
a better defensive square and attacking
the Knight
Queen F3 is another excellent move
we double our Rooks on the e-file and I
actually think that this is still not a
big mistake I think that the main
Mistake by our opponent
uh the first like the the first serious
mistake was to play this move 92.
because it it yields without a fight
control of the e-file and it lets us
play Queen E8 with Tempo and this is a
big Tempo move it's still I think the
position is equal with best defense but
it gets unpleasant here already
so in any case
um I think probably if white wanted to
play accurately then in this position
white should have refrained from
releasing the tension with f take C5
because that really allowed us to uh you
know get rid of the problem of this
passive night and we won the battle over
the e-files so probably White's best
move is something like rookie two this
is an incredibly hard move I mean this
is a grand master level move because
White's just trying to double on the
e-file and White's trying to win the
damn battle over the e-file but a lot of
players would be worried about the look
of the movie four I think
right E4 looks a little scary but if you
calculate after fe4 d4fe4 white actually
has a beautiful tactical idea it's a
gorgeous tactical idea I'll let you guys
try to find it why to play
not F5 F5 doesn't work
because after e takes F3 F takes G so
you have to take the queen and then you
give up The Rook
but you're close the correct sequence
does involve the move F5
now if you think about it what is the
move F5 achieve well it attacks white
Black's Queen it also cuts off the
connection between the queen and the E4
Square so think about what you can start
with
the key is to eliminate the attack on
White's Queen then F5 is going to work
the move is Knight takes C4 yeah very
close Rook takes E4 is also good by the
way but Knight E4 is even better
and the idea is to meet Rook takes C4
with F5 and white is winning
because the queen hangs
black can't get a lot for the queen and
if the queen moves then there's no way
to move the queen and simultaneously
defend the Rook black wins uh White wins
here here
and white is up in exchange so maybe
beautiful was an overstatement but still
very very nice idea
but you kind of would have to see that
when playing rookie two
and if black plays e takes F4 then you
can just play rookie seven rookie seven
Queen F4 and you might say well but
didn't white give up the E file here
well yes but here there's the
extenuating circumstance that the F5
Pawn is now a massive weakness and black
might even have to get away from the
e-file to defend it
but this just shows you how beautiful
positional chess is and how intertwined
tactics are with strategy right that
there's a strategic plan here of
controlling a file but the way that you
control it is you actually use these
super complicated tactics that's why
positional chess is really hard
now a lot of you were asking me to
analyze the move Knight H5
uh Knight H5 I just did analyze well we
looked at it just now uh a couple of
moves ago and we determined that I would
have played F4 of course there were
other moments when white could have
played the move Knight H5 and not in all
of those moments would we have responded
with F4 like for example if y plays
Knight H5 here I'm already not well I
guess still F4 I still think F4 is very
good to trap the Knight and potentially
prepare F3 yeah we would have still
played F4
and even here probably we would have
played F4 so this F4 mechanism was very
strong provided that the Knight wouldn't
be able to reach E4
so back we go to Bishop E5 rookie five
rookie five there was a beautiful tactic
here that I had noticed and it was in
response to Rook F1 which actually I
think Rook F1 was still the best move
and maybe the only remaining way to to
get equality
the move as many of you indicated is
Rook to E3
and the idea is Queen takes C3 Bishop D4
the game is not over
how should white proceed here while
white should give up the queen for the
bishop and snag another Pawn why does
Rook Knight and pawn for the queen but
in such an open position the queen is
able to very often to infiltrate uh the
opponent's Campo and I think black is
winning here or at least black has good
winning chances
but who can spot the brilliant counter
move by white
the tactics aren't over here why does
the defense
I know some of you must be thinking
Knight takes up five but that's not the
move
I read people's mind
F5 is not the move if you actually
calculate Queen c61 is the queen still
yeah the move is actually Queen takes F5
only move Knight F5 is very creative
but a lot of people just kind of stop
calculating here assuming oh I win the
queen back but it's not enough to win
the queen back because black just goes
King F7
if you take the Rook with check then you
give up the piece that's attacking the
queen and if you take the Queen Bishop
D4 is even stronger but the simple Rook
F1 and HG just wins the game on the spot
so
that doesn't cut it Queen takes F5 the
idea is that the queen pays a visit to
C8 with Checkmate in the event the black
takes on G3 with either piece
so black actually has to trade queens
and win the pawn back but I think this
Rook end game if white defends it
carefully is a draw in fact even if
white doesn't defend a careful this is
just a draw because the pawn end game is
losing for black because of the Deep
Freeze so black has to keep the Rooks on
the board and now whites manage to kind
of defend everything
so
this I think was the narrow drawing line
but if our opponent had seen that then I
would have been a little bit suspicious
92 Queen E8 Knight F4 Rook E3 and I
already think the white is losing here
so people watching on YouTube and
thinking that the game was anticlimactic
in fact it's already like minus three
and the reason is that the queen is no
good squares
Queen F2 loses almost immediately
because it aligns the king and the queen
allowing Bishop D4 devastating move and
there's no way to stop all the
discoveries white loose is the queen
um flaming cornbread is asking a
question why not rookie one check oh why
not rookie one check takes here and here
well because Queen takes C6
and I'm afraid that black will not be
able to escape the Perpetual the king is
too weak here the queen has too many
checks so this just seemed way too Josh
and remember that we considered Bishop
E5 G3 and I also think this is maybe
only slightly better for uh for black
so rookie 3 is definitely the move white
should have played Queen F1
but here we don't even really need to do
anything specific the computer stop move
is actually just Bishop to F6
and the idea is to maneuver the bishop
to this beautiful Square on G3 where it
kind of maximally restricts White's
position and sets up ideas of rookie one
so Bishop F6 actually was incredibly
strong here and white is already
essentially paralyzed the Knight is no
squares it is literally restricted by
all of Black's pieces this is incredibly
bad for white
you can play Bishop D4 also but then
white moves the king away and while the
Bishop looks incredibly good on D4 it
would be better placed on G3
because it would be doing a lot more
specific things
so another grand master move Bishop to
F6 H4 and G3 how do you know that you
have time for this well because white is
out of moves and the reason why it is
Adam moves is because you control the
only open file That's The Power of that
so
yeah Queen C6 a disappointing blunder
for sure and we won't analyze after this
but uh the main mistake actually was
this 92 Knight F4 maneuver that's what
lost white the game that really was all
that it was it was like two night moves
on move 27 and 28. so if our opponent
had played Rook F1 the game would have
still been relatively balanced but that
would involve finding this incredible
tactic with Queen F5 so one interesting
kind of narrative that you saw in that
game is that it's not like white you
know White's position deteriorated very
very quickly but that's from a purely
objective standpoint if you reason
practically White made some inaccuracies
earlier in the game that set him up for
this so for example already Fe was an
inaccuracy you could even argue that F4
was a pretty risky move that got the
game very tactical and it increased the
probability that you know stuff was
going to go down and a mistake would
essentially lose the game and that is
oftentimes the difference between open
positions positions with an open Center
positions of the closed Center positions
of the closed Center you don't really
run the risk of losing the game if you
make a small mistake or you put your
piece on the wrong Square that's why
some people prefer you know to play
close positions because you know there's
less at stake with every mistake as
opposed to wide open Center positions
with lots of tactics
um so in any case that was the game it
was a really rich positional game
you know even though it ended up being
pretty short
so I feel like I talked a lot but I hope
you found it productive
um
and that's yet another entry in our
speeder and opening themed speed run as
we start
encountering more principled openings I
think we're already starting to build
our understanding of key typical
positions remember that like training
middle games is actually an extension of
training openings you have to know Key
Middle game ideas that's why in this
game I put a big emphasis on explaining
the logic behind DC and like E5 and
these are all moves that we're going to
play again in the rosalimo
but I'm pretty exhausted that took a lot
of my energy I hope you can appreciate
that
and I'm going to hit the sack
and thanks everybody
for watching thanks for hanging out and
again subscribing to the YouTube it
really helps keep the content going
um that's how I make a living so
you know
so I would really appreciate it and uh
thanks everybody see you tomorrow bye
[Music]